[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Enterprises
have long relied on KPIs
to align all areas
of the business,
and this applies to digital
initiatives as well.
Many executives at
large enterprises
are now connecting the dots
between the performance
of their core business
and their relevance
of digital capabilities
powered by APIs.
To facilitate the next
steps in realizing value
from these critical
assets, enterprises
need to become savvy in the use
of key performance indicators,
or KPIs, to drive
digital programs.
Good KPIs are sometimes not
obvious at first glance,
and supporting metrics
play an important role.
Stronger programs will often
proactively shape their highest
level goals and
KPIs to anticipate
broader transformation.
Following some
important guidelines.
Number 1, focus on driving
growth, breadth, and speed
of API adoption by the
application programs that
depend on them.
2, accelerate the
velocity of iterations
in, not only API
and app development,
but also the creation of user
facing digital experiences.
And 3, align the metrics
of the API program
with developers and channel
partners using those APIs.
We have seen some common
pitfalls when defining metrics
at the onset of API programs.
The program should not be
a standalone P/L function
with metrics set in isolation.
Generally, avoid
using number of APIs
produce as a top line target.
Publishing API is not the
same as creating value
through the consumption
of that API.
Lastly, avoid measuring your
API program like a project.
Targeting and making
decisions on APIs
in traditional terms of
budget, timeline, and quality
will force managers to focus
on completion and timeline,
rather than creating value.
The traditional project
metrics can still
be measured but
always be careful
of incentives and behaviors
this will cast on your team.
Whatever direction you
take, the first step
is to establish KPIs
for your API program
that are direct contributors
to enterprise metrics.
Connect these enterprise
metrics to digital experiences,
and measure the velocity at
which digital experiences are
created.
These are most
important metrics.
In most cases, the API programs
to succeed the enterprise
must align metrics for all
elements of the digital value
chain, including backend
systems, API teams, API
developers, apps, and end users.
This might be a lot to
process at one time,
so let's take a
look, one at a time,
at some possible KPIs
in your API program.
We'll describe what
each one of them
are, their benefits, and some of
the pitfalls and potential sub
metrics.
One common metric we
see is number of APIs.
Often used to drive
short-term productivity,
this target often
ignores the fact
that APIs must also
have easy use utility.
Segment out your APIs by
their various functions
or capabilities
and look for ways
to measure reusability
rather than just volume.
Tracking the number
of developers
is a target commonly
intended to improve adoption.
You can target metrics
developers retention rates,
as well as the number
of active developers
within your community.
Some also use a
conversion funnel approach
to see how they can convert from
developers who are browsing,
registered but not
active, to trial user,
to actual production usage.
Be cautious in making this
a singular focus, though.
Pair this with feedback
from developers
and look at where developers
drop off over time.
Customers don't
experience APIs directly.
They only experience the apps
that they use the APIs with.
Be careful using this KPI.
This target is important,
so measure this
with good API instrumentation
and app analytics.
For example, knowing
how many customers
are connected to all
of your company's apps
using the same
authentication API
would be a great way to showcase
the re-use of that API itself.
Depending on the
type of business
you have, this may or may
not be an immediate KPI.
However, the potential of
APIs to expand your ecosystem
is a powerful capability.
Use this target to
reach out to partners,
drive adoption, and
demonstrate the success
of the platform expansion.
This is a key ecosystem
metric for any platform.
This target may be
useful to drive reach.
Use this target by segmenting
the apps of partner
and/or internal and
by line of business.
If the program creates a lot
of apps that are only used
internally and not
by customers, it
can sometimes feed internal
criticism and abandonment
of the program.
This one is a great
productivity metric.
In order to enable app teams
to rapidly create new customer
experiences, API teams should
become adept at quickly
turning around needed APIs.
Some teams will create a metric
called time to hello world
describing and benchmarking
the end to end time
to create a very basic API.
You can define it any way
you want, but it's a catchy
and instantly
understood concept.
Reducing developer friction
to access your API platform
is a key target.
Start measuring this
early on and distinguish
between the duration
for the initial signup,
the duration it takes
to get apps approved,
to the duration it takes
to go live with an app.
Traffic growth helps with
both indication of usage
but also scalability.
This target helps API programs
develop a strong DevOps
and RunOps culture by
continuously monitoring,
improving, and driving
value through the APIs.
Be sure to target this
with a related metrics
up and down the value chain,
including latency, reliability,
and scalability.
This target focuses
the API program
to build relevance
across the business
and to drive re-use of the APIs
through backend assets they
connect to.
Particularly valuable APIs, such
as those that provide access
to unique data or
proprietary functionality,
may become a greater
asset to partners
and provide entrance
to new markets.
This KPI also helps the
team escalate blockers
to the proper executive
level for resolution.
APIs themselves don't
always reduce costs,
but they are critical to broader
internal refactoring of value
chains, which do reduce costs.
It can be hard to
initially measure
cost reduction from
APIs, and sometimes it
stirs dissent amongst managers.
Significant cost reductions are
usually realized from the rise
in API reuse and
increase in APIs,
allowing the company
to purchase more
of the off-the-shelf software.
For example, HR can replace old
internal systems and process
by exposing the data through
APIs to better Cloud-based HR
software, even more compelling.
Instead of taking
capital investment
and building new consumer
facing or customer facing
applications, the
company can invite
partners to co-innovate and
build multiple experiences,
leveraging the company's
APIs and core assets.
This leads to a reduction
from reduced research
and development spend within
the company and in relation
to the speed and
market, the new channels
the company is able to access
by going to multiple markets
with multiple partners.
Direct revenue can be
a tricky KPI to target.
APIs are enablers.
They need an adoption cycle
before proving their relevance
to revenue, also it's a
purely API Business model.
If you're not one of
these kinds of businesses,
you might see a way
to upcharge and claim
a share of the revenue
for the usage of your APIs
similar to cost of goods
sold or chargeback method.
Instead of targeting NPS of
those digital experiences,
use NPS to gauge the
app developers who
are adopting and calling
APIs from within their apps.
To get even more
detailed, you can
measure the NPS
between internal app
developers versus external
and partner app developers.
In early stages, your
APIs and documentation
may be really immature.
So NPS is less useful than
just getting qualitative user
feedback.
Another aspect to target
is the quality of APIs.
Track response times,
error rates on your APIs,
and whether they meet the SLA
and standards you're expecting.
Don't boil the ocean and focus
your team on a handful or less
of measurements that are
important to the program's
success.
You can prioritize them
or change them over time.
KPIs are metrics
are living tools
and should be
revisited periodically.
What is important
at the beginning
will not be important later on.
Here's an example how we
suggest pacing these metrics
and their focus areas over time.
When getting started
in the crawl phase,
track the number and type of
APIs producing the engagement
of the app developers.
Focus on execution improvement
with KPIs for speed and quality
of API development.
Once APIs are in
use, shift the focus
to adoption and increase
of the ecosystem.
Focus on the number of apps,
the number of partners,
or the number of
customers that are
using the newly minted APIs.
Once a good production
cadence around APIs
is operational
and begins to run,
add more familiar
business impact
reporting to the dashboard,
such as direct revenue, NPS,
breadth of business, and
cost reduction as agreed to
with the rest of
the executive team.
If you want more
information, please check out
the community for
ebooks, articles,
and other related topics.
Thank you for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]